Because I did tell him that.
Oh my god. Oh, so you think it's okay to just like tell the truth
about your friends? I thought I thought he was your friend. Yeah,
that's not Yeah, I don't I I actually don't believe we should
just like sweep for people because we like them. Are you similar
to Tommy C stuff from tonight or I haven't watched I woke up
and I was like I was seeing like all these messages. People were
like he streamed for 4 hours about this guy and it's like
blocked by my chat right now. This is explicitly Queman. Queman
the the streamer Queman at Queenman live is coordinating ladders
in Tommy C's chat actively right now.
Right at this very well sorry as of a couple hours ago. That's
up dude. That's right. That's that's that's what coming next.
I would be like like I am now like oh I'm a coward. Well right
that's not you. You're freaking out Chud
absolutely raped you. Those are Chud guys.
We've already fully established that you totally Jedi mind trick
Chud into covering whatever you want him to cover. You probably
Jedi mind trick him into telling his chatters to come and do
ladders in Tommy's chat. Let's uh let's be real. Mihawk is a
hater. Yeah, that's because you soped him into being a hater
obviously. Do you think we don't know how this goes? Do you not
understand that I am fully informed on how to maintain a conspiracy?
Okay. You do something that works against your interest, that's
because you're manipulating people. You do something that works
in your interest. Yeah, it's because you're manipulating people.
Okay. I You think I don't see this? You think I can't run this
narrative? I I'm very experienced. Okay. Behind the scenes interactions
directly to the person involved. I'm getting
my third party. That's kind of funny. Where's that man? Such
a snake. Okay. I got 15 minutes. I don't know. Qu in the chat.
Do you want to come talk about this for a minute? Cuz I feel
like I've gotten I feel like I've heard his response to almost
everything Chud's going to say already. He's like sort of walked
those out. I don't think I'll get a lot unique from going through
the whole video. Although, I probably will if you want to hop
in for a little bit. I'm just, you know, I'm here. I don't know
how much longer we're going. So, here, I'll hop in the the chat
for a little bit here.
If I'm Yeah, he loops like crazy. Well, I'm guessing he pre-watched
a lot of Chud's stream before he went and did this, right? So,
I'm guessing that what we're actually going to get here is him
going over the same points over and over and over and over again.
What's up? Hi. How's it going? Oh, did you I thought I thought
you said but it was a n I got it. I got it. Don't do that. You'll
be timed out. Don't do it. I think kickshot's getting right now
anyway. Seems like it's kind of falling apart. Awesome. What
can you do? What can you
Yeah. I Okay. So, what are like the the primary points here?
I think the the primary points have got to be the Bolex call,
him talking to Tom. What? So, I missed it or I didn't ask my
chat even I can't remember from the first video. His turkey tom
thing wasn't Chud calling him out on the cons the Molina consent
or sorry, the pixie consenting argument, right? And saying Molina
didn't. It was something else. What What else did Chud call him
out on that video?
Oh, sure. That's probably true. Revenge thing or about the community
as well? It was It was like Chud pressed Tom on something. Oh,
it was that they were scared of DG, right? Yeah, I think that
was the thing he called, but that I don't think that was like
the heart of press he did at all. I think that was him kind of
that and the Molina Pixie thing and um
that was uh
Yeah. And
what else was in that chat? Um it it was just saying come on.
Obviously wasn't consensual. Obviously that that's what they're
Tommy's cop about.
Um, oh, did he eventually get to that part because I think in
his first video he really didn't mention the of course it wasn't
consensual. And to me that was like where he pressed way harder.
And so the point I made the point that I made about that just
now or a little while ago, I don't know if you heard it, but
it's like literally the only way you could be upset about that
is if you can only see things in a world where you're like where
you base everybody's value on how nice they are to Nicholas Dario
and Turkey Tom, right? Like when you don't have any view of how
like Chud looks in that stream if he allows that to happen and
says nothing and then it comes out that he knew about it, right?
Yeah. Like like that's the only world you have to operate in.
And if you can see it from any other person's perspective, you
don't get mad at Chud for pressing there. At least not on the
on the Oh, I we don't know. No, they all have to. No, Jason,
you don't understand. They they Nick and Tom decided that it
was staying quiet and they weren't going to say anything about
it. So, everyone has to adhere to that. Okay. I like Yeah. I
don't understand the way he talked about it either where he was
like they didn't want to give Destiny notice at all. It's like
what do you mean give Destiny notice? Already talking about it.
What? Well, the only reason any of them knew knew what was happening
was because straight away straight away was sharing the DMs around.
That's why Chard knew. That's why Nick knew. Yeah. Like it was
already What do you mean tip Destiny off?
What the does that mean? Uh yeah. I Well, and also like it's
not like Chud had information or his opinion was based on anything
outside of like he might have had some idea there, right, that
the the DMs were surely non-conent. But like I think he probably
would have had that opinion as a lot of people would have had
that opinion as I had that opinion, right? I think you and I
had that opinion and I don't think we were privy to any of this
information that Strader was leaking the DMs, right? you I Yeah,
you and I stated that opinion multiple times. Like although although
we don't know for sure, like it seems almost certain that there
there's no way he had full consent of all these people to share
this. Yep. So, so yeah. Anyway, Chud Chud could have had that.
It tips nobody off to have that position basically.
And yeah, I think he's just totally fine to press on that.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't get any other argument.
the Boax thing. The the kind of counterpoint to the Boax thing
is, okay, so Chud's the snake for making the joke in public when
you guys basically trashed Boax's reputation to his entire community.
All sharing this dress photo around in the background cuz Connor
screenshotted it or some from the gender vlogs that Boax is sending
him. And you're like sharing this picture around between your
little groups. That's Well, I didn't know it was Augby,
but I I definitely that was my point here is like I think you
I think you guys are like freaks for trying to defend trying
to like trying to moralize Chudlogic leaking that when you were
all on this guy for the same thing behind the scenes. It's like
dude, you shared that picture around more than Destiny shared
his wife's like non-consensual
non-conensually shared his wife's to people. Okay, it just wasn't
even a bit like I was saying it wasn't even a big leak at that
point because everyone already knew Bob was non-binary. Everyone
had seen that he was trying all the stuff from Victoria's Secret.
Like there was so much it was already all there and all Chud
said was there's a photo of him in a dress that exists. That's
but that's it. That was the only piece of information that was
revealed.
And we all wish that that's where it stopped, right? We all wish
that it stopped with just leaking that he had a trust picture
on. Also, he says like a million times across the stream he keeps
going, "Oh, they wouldn't have found the only fans if Chad hadn't
leaked that." And at the very end, one of his [__]
co-hosts is like, "Uh, just say that there's no way that could
be true because they found it from Boax leaking his emails on
stream." And then Tommy keeps trying to defend it for like another
minute. And then he goes, "No, no, seriously, there's no way
it could be true." And Tommy finally conceds on it after saying
it the entire stream for like five hours.
Wait, is that Wait, which stream is that on? You talking about
this one? Oh, yeah. We're not there yet. Okay. All
Uh, yeah. I don't I don't even know.
I don't know what criticisms could even um
I I don't know if I'm going to watch any more of this on stream
to tell you the truth. Like I I'll probably watch for a little
bit longer, but it seems like it's a painful watch. I'm going
to be real. Like I think we've gotten through basically every
I I've noticed him loop back on the same arguments like twice
now and it's like okay, he's not gonna have anything else. Yep.
Yeah. It's not going to there's not going to be like newer novel
things. Uh is there anything newer novel that you think comes
out after the about hour in? It's just there's just like funny
moments I think more than anything. It's just like funny if you
just don't like Tommy C
embarrassing himself for several hours.
Oh boy. Did uh what what else been going on
I cover earlier? Oh,
I covered um did you see short fat otaku arguing with this helibe
person
on
Um it was around like some Destiny stuff cuz SFO had like this
take.
Where the [__] do I have it here? I I'll get your
opinion on this cuz I think this more like to be honest is more
interesting than the rest of this. I'm like invested in this
as far as it goes but like Oh
Whoops. I don't know why I had that up.
Um, okay. Sorry, sorry, sorry. What are we Why do I keep on clicking
on these
Oh, I have a different Never mind. Don't worry about it, guys.
We're safe. I need sleep is what I need. I was looking at a different
window. Don't worry about it, Queenie. You didn't see anything.
I'm talking to myself. There we go. There's the short fatu
me. Okay,
so Destiny and Pixie were fighting on Twitter a couple days ago.
SFO came in with this. Destiny legitimately has some behavior
needs to apologize for. make amends for in this story. Then he
says, "Pixie has clearly been using the court system in bad faith,
making untrue claims, using the process to silence criticism.
Neither of these wash away the other. Both are true."
And this le person comes in. Oh, sorry. Destiny will probably
win the court case as I don't think the available evidence rises
to that level. I don't believe that means he's innocent of all
wrongdoing. Far from it. Meanwhile, Pixie's own victimization
doesn't give her a free pass to be unhinged and weaponize the
system. Libby says, "What are you talking about?" Dev says, "I've
since looked over the whole case. Destiny's far from innocent,
but so is Pixie. Turns out she shared the tape with people behind
his back as well last time I checked. Plus, her actions in court
have been uh not great." And basically,
Ellie is going to this is going to be a a spinning loop repeatedly
of Ellie going, "Oh, what evidence do you have of that?" And
him going, "Well, I I read it somewhere and now I I don't know.
I have it in an archive for research, but could you explain to
me why like this wouldn't be true?" So, here we'll go down. Oh,
so you just believe the thing Destiny completely lied about.
Whatever. Not worth arguing with anyone who still takes his word
as gospel. Let me know if you ever break out of that. Deb responds,
"If you have proof he lied, I'd like to see it. As I said, I've
been looking over everything I can get my hands on, whether it's
proesty or anti. He and I are not friends. I'm just interested
in the truth." And it's like, "Okay, then why are you taking
what? Where's your evidence of this? Where did you get
Yeah. Where did you get the idea that she shared it with people
behind his back?" Reading the KF thread, I think I've archived
everything. I've seen for future video on for a future video
on the topic. If you have evidence it's wrong, send it my way
and I'll archive that, too. Well, can you show the evidence that
it's true? Can you show me why you think this at all? And Deb
is like Deb can make persuasive video essays. I know he's capable
of researching. So, for me, I I like straight up sat here cuz
I asked him to come on my stream. He's never not responded to
me when I asked him like something about the stream, by the way.
And he kept tweeting after this. So, I'm pretty sure he saw.
He's like, "Bro, could you you want to just come talk about this?
I have no idea. Like literally just show it. Like you don't have
to come on any streams. Just like this is you're making a specific
line. Oh, sure. Sure. Pixie shared this video with people behind
bag. Okay. Show us that. Where's that coming from? Yeah. Very
simple. Very simple ask.
I think he's referencing her ex-boyfriend. So, Evil Morty, this
is what he's referencing. Okay. So
about three weeks ago now, three weeks agoish, Pixie said in
a response to one of Destiny's motions, um what that what Destiny's
like, you know, motion here says is untrue. Uh he knows that
I that I said it was okay for him to be possibly sharing with
Molina and he said it was okay for me to share with my boyfriend
explicitly. We had those explicit conversations. They were part
of the same conversation, right? And then basically Destiny had
no response to that. He didn't go and say like, "Oh, no, that's
fake. That's wrong. That's totally like not anything." He just
said nothing until apparently in court
as far as he he says that Pixie said she shared it without explicit
consent.
Right. But that's basically Pixie said she shared it. He never
said it was without explicit consent before. He's never responded
to it. He said, "Oh, this is a shocking revelation that she said
she shared it with her ex-boy." Well, he's even confirmed that
at some point or almost at least said about Molina. He said that
they had conversations about sharing it with Yes. Yes. or whatever.
Like it's just
all the evidence aligns with the idea that this was the case.
Whatever.
Oh, hold on. Let me do this. So, Erdite went on the Turkey Tom
stream and said this. So, one,
it's possible that Destiny um
it's possible that he, you know,
how would you put this at this point? It's like possible that
he's misremembering or something or I I have no idea. But Erid,
I I forgot, went on Turkey Tom's thing and said explicitly like
Destiny said he doesn't really remember, but he's pretty sure
he didn't get Pixie's consent or something along those lines,
right? Which kind of lines up contemporaneously with his admission
that he violated her consent in the worst way imaginable, right?
But at minimum, Destiny told Erdite he just doesn't remember
at all. Right? That's that's what he said. That was the first
thing he said was, "I don't really remember, but I'm pretty sure
I didn't get her consent." Is you can listen to it. You tell
me if you hear it differently. In Miami in like early December
when I went down in person cuz I wanted to talk to him in person
and I was like what the is this? Um and I asked him did she know
Oh, you're not okay. Miami in like early December when I went
down in person cuz I wanted to talk to him. I was like, "What
the is this?" Um and I asked him did she know you're recording
and did she consent to it? Um he said that she did know about
the recording. Like she's aware she did consented to the actual
filming of it, but that he said specifically
probably not. Um like it was 3 years ago. I don't remember specifically
and like things were open like this, but yeah, probably not.
I didn't get like explicit consent. And I said, Stephen, that's
really like that's not okay. Um and so just to be so stupid,
man. She's such a dude. It's actually so crazy. So, like as far
as I can tell, uh I believe Erdite should have to testify at
one of these. Like they should actually subpoena Arodite to testify
and say like say what you believe on the on the record right
now.
Stephen, that's not okay.
Oh,
did she watch the rile video? Did you watch the rile video from
today? I did watch the video. Yeah. Holy,
dude.
I paused it like right before she said she like said something
and I'm like, "Hold on, I can feel it." she's about to do. It's
bad. And then she said it's not good.
God, it's just Listen, it's just bad. No, I don't have any like
recommendations. I don't believe you have to do anything to remedy
bad behavior. I think you can just act bad and I'll forgive you
infinitely. But, you know, it's it means something when I say
it's bad, doesn't it, guys? Even if I, you know, I don't actually
do anything when you've done really bad acts repeatedly over
and over and over and over again.
She disavows.
What does she disavow? She disavows Destiny's faction the one
time. Oh, also the best part about she disavows being a goofy
goona. Okay, you shouldn't be a goofy goona. That's what you
shouldn't do. Okay, the best part about this, and I don't think
we ran with this narrative that much of the time, and it really
should have been the main narrative was he doesn't care about
consent explicitly. He explicitly disregards consent because
there's the Bob 7 video, and I know I made this point, but it
is like probably the strongest point in retrospect. There's the
Bob 7 video where Molina sits him down and says, "Hey, you didn't
have my explicit consent to send this to more people. Please
stop sending my to people that I don't know." And then we get
the Rose Leaks. And we see that he sent more of Molina's to people
she doesn't know. Everyone, we've all been there, though, right?
We've all been there.
So, like when says, "I feel like this guy needs to be punished."
She's actually right. There are no social con. There are no consequences
for this that he actually cares about. Uh yeah, there's no there's
no consequences he cares. Yeah, there's no conse uh consequences
he cares about at all. Like he he needs monetary consequences.
Sorry. There's no um You've never done this, J. Don't Don't act
like you've never done this. Stop you've never done this. Yeah,
I I literally Yeah, I have not. I have not,
Dude. And I don't even believe that this is like the the norm.
It's especially not the norm with people who uh have public platforms.
Oh, it's Judas. Oh, but he's gone. He left.
Um, don't he wants to come back. Make him come back. Make him
come back. Make him come defend Tommy. Say, make him No, I want
him to come back and explain why. Uh, what what the did he do?
Did he leak something? Oh, he said something about Chud. I just
I just called him out on dual loyalty like 10 minutes ago.
Now I can't remember. It was from the first part. Where Where's
Tom? Call him back in here. Right. Get this loser back in here,
man.
Hold on. I'll find the transcript right
Veno, but we find out later that it's a lie because Aiden said
I specifically told him I remember telling him that this was
private information.
So Aiden Aiden came out and explicitly said that he gave that
he he said it was private information. Wait, what the why did
I just hear Aiden say you talk about Destiny? The going on with
my just joined. Well, I just saw him pop in now. It was like
way after.
Yeah, you're good. Yeah, I don't know. I don't know if I missed
something. Um, what's up?
Uh, why did you rat Chud out to the world and say, "No, I explicitly
told everybody. I explicitly told Chud that this was private
information. Don't leak the Boax thing." Why'd you judice him
like that? Did you get 40 pieces of silver from Nick? Well, because
I did tell him that.
Oh my god. Oh, so you think it's okay to just like tell the truth
about your friends? I thought I thought he was your friend. Yeah,
that's Yeah, I don't I I actually don't believe we should just
like sweep for people because we like them. Are you similar to
Tommy C stuff from Tonight Aiden or I haven't watched I woke
up and I was like I was seeing like all these messages people
were like he's streamed for 4 hours about this guy and it's like
there's no shot in hell I'm watching four hours of this coverage.
What's
when are you streaming again? Tomorrow like
you got to cover the Tommy C stuff. Yes, but I don't think I'm
going to cover the full 4 hour stream.
Uh, we'll just do like the first I'd say Chad's response. You
don't even really need to be honest. You don't need Chud's responses
to any of it. Watch just like watch like the first video, then
watch the second video and then get like a taste of this stream
from today, but it's not really that good. Maybe get someone's
time sent me some good bits or something. Well, my question how
long how many hours
got sucks.
I heard like he's just called them diggers repeatedly. I called
them deckers. Deckers. Deckers. Deckers. Oh, he called them diggers,
too. Okay. Why did he Why is he getting roped into this now?
Cuz um DMs from Tommy Dick. No, Tommy leaked DMs with because
um
uh Tommy's dyslexic and misread a message wrote in his Discord
um where he thought was saying that DMs were odd and Tommy was
like, "Our DMs aren't odd, but was actually saying it felt odd
to leak DMs cuz Tommy had replied and didn't want to leak Tommy's
reply." Um, and then Tommy leaked the DMs sparking out and then
deleted the message. And so the the DMs are basically after he
went on Tommy's and called whatever is coming and begging for
forgiveness, apologizing cuz he wants to be in the Dioro house.
It's very pathetic from from to be honest. He actually I mean
I have a DM I sent to Tommy where I said I'm not in a conspiracy
against you. Um, but I was doing that just so he didn't like
because I was cool to just spur Tommy. Just letting you know
I'm not in a conspiracy against you. Yeah, I know. I realize
in hindsight that I like that's the most suspicious thing I could
ever send to him cuz it looks like it makes it look like I am
in a conspiracy against him, but apparently wrote like an apology
essay.
Yeah, he did.
Dude, sad stuff. Sad stuff.
What are you guys covering? Are you Destiny right now? Well,
no. We just got into Destiny. Really? Because stuff? Yeah. How
long do you stream? Did you say how many hours? How many hours?
Uh,
like six, seven, maybe. Jesus, you lazy. What? You got compete
with Ch.
Yeah, I'm going to compete. I don't I was not competing. I still
get like decent viewership when he's live.
Wow. So, maybe Tommy should have been trying to try to be special
of you instead. Is that uh is that are is the cabal ordering
you to do that? You need to conflict with Chud's time slot now.
Cover the versus Tommy C drama while Chud's live and take Tommy
C's side. That's the plan.
True. All right. Well, I'll let you guys. I'm going to hijack
her. You guys get back to piece peace.
Okay. See you. Okay.
I can't even remember what what we're on.
Is this you were talking about how you wanted to um Oh, hold
on. I was gonna say you were gonna do gay, but
Okay.
Okay. The most important thing. Okay.
Regardless of what you've heard online or regardless of Oh, wait,
wait, wait. This is going to be good. Sit for me or on me or
sent for anybody else or whatever. Obviously, this is going to
be this good. Taking any things or sharing any things non-consensually,
it's never good. Don't ever do that. Don't defend that. Don't
be that guy. I only said that because I saw some people were
typing over the past week who were like, "Oh, like this doesn't
matter. Who cares even if this did happen or whatever." That's
not cool. Okay. Wasn't he just in DG chat like a week ago talking
about how um all all forms of uh consent are mostly infor uh
implied consent, right? He's like almost all consent is implied
consent.
It's like okay, you can you can play that game if you want that
like oh most physical personal interactions are like implied
consent. You don't usually ask to do every single thing you do,
but why why it's such a weird like non it it it doesn't map on
at all. This is the sharing of somebody's like private video
with another person of every time I I have for the girl. I make
knows exactly what's happening four business days in advance
like okay man. Uhhuh. Is he knows half of his audience are Indian
incelss now. Listen, let's not on the Indians here. Okay. W India
W India so number one don't be that guy okay number one who's
defending anything like that okay don't do that anyway
sorry back to this le dev thing okay so dev's making these arguments
these arguments we keep going
where do we get down to
okay yeah so he he basically says I got it from reading the KF
thread and I'm like bro how can you up the you've basically this
up and done the only wrong way you can site KF is essentially
not having any primary source and either I mean okay maybe he's
just quoting he's either quoting Destiny right but saying he's
quoting KF so he's quoting like a KF clip of Destiny or he's
quoting some random KF poster with no actual concrete underlying
source which is the only way you shouldn't use KF right you you
shouldn't just take somebody's like theory on how something happened
KF is useful as a source because you can ar they have archives
of things specifically like making points and and you can say
even being against the creator right That's most of the threads
on there or to archive pieces of information that like cut against
the creator. So, it's like it's valid to use primary sources
from there, but it's not really valid to go and take like a theory
somebody put together or what somebody says is what happened.
You should just be archiving the p you should be archiving for
yourself the primary sources there that they've archived. I don't
know. I don't know why he [__] us up. Sad.
So, clearly it didn't originate in the KF thread. I'm asking
you what evidence you saw to support it. I don't fully record
or I don't fully recall, which is why I said in the original
tweet last I checked, I know I have suff uh I have it stuffed
away somewhere, but I'm open to being wrong. What do you have?
So, he just keeps trying to pull this back to like, how do you
know lying? How do you know? Look for it now. You're sitting
here at your computer tweeting. Yes. Yes. Exactly.
You've had the time. You literally told you told us all you have
it. So, I think this is why he didn't want to come on stream
because I assume he knows
like and he knows it. So, what what is the goal here? I'm messaging
myself at this point. I'm just sending a message.
spend ages
arguing about
what Destiny did. Why you could spend that time pulling up the
screenshot?
seems counterproductive.
Exclamation mark where WRT early
argument
on Twitter. There we go. Okay. All right. Yeah. I don't know.
And this guy's always when I asked this guy a question, he responds
like that day. Like he's he's pretty online, right? He tweets
all the time.
I I was basically like I asked him, I was like, "Hey, you want
to come on stream and like discuss this?" Cuz I I think this
cuts against like a bunch of his principles. He's supposed to
be like a liberal guy, right? classical liberal, but not the
Nazi kind like Sargon. The kind that like actually Sargon does
not pretend to be a classical liberal anymore. Yeah, I know.
I know. They were just friends when Sargon started saying that.
Yeah. Yeah. But Ellie makes like a bunch of really good arguments
back here. This this person's actually like they make really
good arguments. I don't know. Yeah. She's uh she's one of my
dieards on Twitter as well. We love We love Ellie. Eli B again.
Okay. I think it's got to be Ellie, right? Not Eli. I think I
think it's Eli. Sometimes I read as Eli, but it's got to be Ellie.
Anyway,
so what I have is a pretty big problem because I know where it
came from. A completely basis claim from Destiny about an event
that his his close friend claims he doesn't remember, which is
counteracted by earlier court filings and his own words. This
is why I think it's important to maintain the expectation that
people who make affirmative claims against his victims should
be able to substantiate them because his strategy is clearly
to damage his victims to try to shut them up and shut and other
victims up. sorry to shut them and other victims up. I will send
you what I have, but it's untenable for Steven to come to be
able to come out with a new smear every day and the burden to
be placed on his victims who are in an impossible position regarding
defending themselves publicly to disprove them. He's like, well,
I don't want anybody to shut up because of what I've posted and
I don't think that'll happen. I have no reach, but I'm willing
to see what you have. Thank you. You know what would really solve
his problem of not having reach, Kleman? Can you guess? What
do you think? Shilling for conservatives. shilling for mega.
Uh, no. If um if he kept making points that were exclusively
pro Destiny and then out of nowhere,
a certain guy appears in the Oh, wait. He's not in these replies.
He's here somewhere. He replies somewhere.
Where was it? Was it this one? Hold on. It might be this one.
Oh, what? There's Destiny reply there where Destiny literally
comes in and starts reply like right.
It's like I'm just making totally arguments. I'm making a complete
act of myself. And now apparently Destiny's going to come and
defend me. Cool.
Yeah, I have the wrong thread here.
But anyway,
and he comes by and he basically goes, "This person has nothing.
They became a deranged anti fan a couple years ago. It's easy
to say whatever you want online. It's a lot harder when you're
under oath. There's a reason they wanted the transcripts sealed
and I want the transcripts open." Uh, le mercilessly them by
the way as well. It's pretty
Uh, where is it? Here.
yeah, right here. You may not want that. So, to for people to
shut up, but you're contributing to it. Let's say for argument
sake that it's a blatant lie from Steven, but people are blindly
accepting his fact anyway. Do you see how this would be a deterrent
to future victims coming forward? Yes, but I think that needs
to be weighed against my own obligation to put my forward to
put forward my honest opinion which I believe to be true
now. I know Dev has done a lot of content making fun of people
doing spirious like assault claims, right? But what were those
people doing if not putting forward their honest opinion without
fact a factual basis to it? Quan,
what what were those people? Okay, so what was that? Sorry, what
you asking me? Oh, sorry. So Dev makes a bunch of his content
based on doing reviews, right? Or sorry, based on mocking women
who do like spirious claims. Spirious like uh assault or harassment
claims. like he's got a bunch of content making fun of women
who who get like way over over their skis with this stuff. And
what are they doing if not putting forward their honest opinion
which they believe to be true,
right? Like obviously you shouldn't just put your honest opinion
out there if you have absolutely no basis for it and it's like
possibly harmful to people, right?
Uh yeah, fantastic engagement. So do you think this is generally
true coming from people making allegations of misconduct? they
should come forward with what they
if if they feel it to be true regardless of the strength of the
evidence for and against it. He says, "Hold on, we can have that
this discussion, but first, what do you have?" So, he realizes
he's totally and he just like opts out. He's like, "Wait, hold
on. You still haven't given me your like negative evidence. You
still haven't he still haven't disproven what Destiny said."
And she kind of has. She's kind of proved she's kind of proved
this out, right? or sorry, she's at least given some evidence
to support her side, even though Dev's not actually given his,
you know, uh, his primary source on this. So, we go from here.
I believe this is where Destiny replies. I wonder if he scrolled
Oh, if he scrolled my timeline and saw what I have, including
court filings, which are literally under penalty of perjury,
and that's why he's responding behind a block so his fans can't
see it. So, I think,
which one was it? Was it one of these? She quote tweets him after
uh he opens things up,
but I can't look at his quote tweets because I am blocked by
him. Unlucky. Press the three dots. Press the three dots on the
tweet. You post engagements.
Oh, why is the quote button blocked? Oh, it's fairy queen based.
I have to find this other Ellie tweet. But anyway, it goes down
to there and then she starts asking. Oh, wait. I do have I do
have at least the responses, right? Yeah. Oh, come on. I've got
the responses somewhere, don't I? She didn't reply here. She
did like a quote tweet of
But it's not uh it's not anywhere here. [__] me.
Where did I have this before? Sorry. I ran the segment when I
was not tired. How did I find this when we were running the segment
the first time? I actually don't even remember. Oh, I know how
I found it. Hold on. No, no, no. I know how I found it. I have
it somewhere else. Right. Yes. Sorry. This is it right here.
So, she eventually goes and uh what? Takes a picture. Oh, takes
a picture. Says cute of him to say this all behind a block. Bro,
bro is ah Bro is smiling hard. He used to at least unblock me
when he wanted to talk in order to keep me from criticizing him.
Oh, good. I have some questions for you. With how many women
have you relied on implied consent to share of ballpark if you're
not sure? Was Kylin lying when you said you couldn't remember
whether you gave consent? And he memes. Okay. Mom joke. Your
mom joke. Uh, she says, "I can't imagine why you wouldn't want
to answer this question. Implied consent is a legitimate form
of consent, right? When do we get a queen head padote?" Um, probably
not ever. Queen's avatar and stream. Oh, what's up, Dan? How's
it going, Dan? You can join the channel right now. Dan, do you
want to come out in to the channel and explain to Que how doesn't
support the ADL? Calan tell us about about the ADL and and Destiny,
Steven, Destiny, Kenneth, Banell II. No, we don't have to talk
about Destiny. That's like personal and that's Destiny's that's
Dan's uh business partner. Okay. I just love to talk about the
ADL.
Just a little bit little word on the ADL. Possibly. Possibly.
I'm I'm so exhausted. I misspe more than Dan right now. This
up. Oh, what is this? Just to be clear, Kylo was lying when you
said you didn't remember if Pixie gave consent. Probably not.
I know you enjoyed laring as a teenage boy, but this is a serious
matter. That's all that's the reason you're engaging this conversation
after all. You know it. So, basically, she's like, "Oh, he's
just trying to talk behind a block. He won't engage." And then
he proceeds to just not engage with anything,
right? If this is if this is serious and the answers are important,
I'm sure you're looking forward to seeing the transcript just
as much as everyone else. Oh, he keeps going back to the sealed
transcript is like the sealed transcript holds the truth. Okay,
it holds the proof that everybody is perjuring themselves to
go against me. Transcript to your procedural hearing, oh, sorry.
The transcript to your procedural hearing contains the answer
to the question of whether Kylo is lying about what she told
Tom about you or how many other women you've spread of based
on implied consent. Must have been a wild hearing. or you've
just found a new thing to cling on to to deflect from all the
allegations against you in a desperate attempt to save your career
and prevent your other victims from coming forward. Who can really
say? I love this one. The nice thing about hearings is that you're
striking your your staking, sorry, your name and your reputation
on the things that you're saying as being true. No one knows
or cares who you are on this platform. You'd be an idiot to expect
serious engagement once uh once here once this is on here on
here once this has gotten to the litigation stage. Thanks for
playing though. Um, I'm just so glad that he thinks it's really
important and things have a lot of weight when people are staking
their names in legal filings because that's kind of the basis
for this whole thing going to discovery is is the Abby affidavit
that says, "Hey, he shared things non-conensually with me that
she somehow predicted that he had videos of all these people
or videos or whatever of these people, right?" It's it's amazing
that he's willing to reaffirm that. That's really important having
your name on these things. Love it. Okay, because that's it's
going to be the basis for this whole thing going
Did Dan respond to us? Did he say he's going to come on? No.
He said in a few
Did he actually say in a few months?
I hope he's doing another round of bats. He's doing another round
of Twitch bats.
Wait, has Dan been wearing the catsuit on anything else? I actually
don't know. Dan, have you been Have you been wearing the catsuit,
Dan?
You lost. You wore it. You wore it once. That wasn't the That
was not the bet. Send the That was not the bed at all.
Okay. All right. Well,
anyway, Ellie B and Destiny, good times.
Classic stuff. Really? Oh, yeah. Hold on. Dan says, "Yeah, I
know. But he's not checking up on it." So, he knows that he's
You know, I'll I won't say one J word. I'll use I'll use a G
word instead. You're kind of jipping XQC on this bet right now.
Okay. I there's a what? There's another thing I was going to
say, but Dan, I understand the power you have. Okay. I do not
want to be
We'll say we'll say we'll say chip. We'll say that. Okay.
Another group destroyed in the Holocaust, by the way. Like absolutely
catastrophically catastrophically demolished in the Holocaust.
So,
okay. Please don't over this death squads to put a bullet in
the end. Please. Okay. We've gone way over time on the stream
and I like I said, I'm getting closer to like actually sleeping
correctly. Poor stream, guys. Okay. Uh be back tomorrow. Can
cover Hassan. Everybody's favorite dude. Hassan getting proven
correct that the government is going after him for standing with
freedom fighters in the Middle East. Okay. Up stuff. You hate
to see it.
Queen gets the foreskin replacement. Jesus Christ. This guy's
got some weird thoughts. What's wrong with this guy? This guy's
got some stuff going on. He probably You know what, Dan? I'm
just going to make it clear right now. Okay, I disavowed in the
moment and I disavowed again the Rust October 7th comments. Okay,
that was a joke. It was only said in justest. It was just pure
comedy. Okay, was not serious.
Disavow. Disavow those comments. Oh yes, the pirate coverage
tomorrow as well. Yes, we will get to the pirate coverage.
Yes, is coming, guys. I've got Longneck coming on the show later.
Long Neck's backstage right now. I don't know what you're referring
to, but awesome. Cool.
Okay, that's it for us, guys. We're done for the evening. Is
it real drama or is it Cuz I hate that. Oh, it is real drama.
I think somebody somebody basically posted all of their logs
with him and said like he's abusive. And he's probably not like
super abusive in the logs, but they are very embarrassing. Dan,
it is a bunch of gay furry logs, okay? And him like calling this
person his little woof. And yeah, it's a ton of gay furry logs,
okay? Like hardcore
shot proof that this guy is a furry and engages in all kinds
of furry play. But then he he posted that like this person totally
failed to cancel him before. And apparently this person had their
own logs that proved that he was lying. Okay, Queenman is my
little wolf wolf. Tell him to bark for me. Hold on. I got a soundboard
for this. Why is this guy's
I this guy from your channel. What the what the hell? Okay. Sexually
harassing
Yeah, true. Very, very, very good stuff. Okay. We'll be back
tomorrow, guys. I love you all. I'm going to raid
nobody cuz nobody I know is online. Okay. All right. That's it
for us, guys. Be back tomorrow. Bye-bye. Good night. Have a good
one. See you. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Oh,
by the way, sub for the Patreon if you want image perms back
on the Discord losers. Goodbye.